agora
votar é pesquisar e se desculpa por não
iria pra ganhar nos próximos 20 minutos
é e quer usar por vendas neste mergulho
no que é ser liberada é ea procura por
ela que é mais ou menos por significado
e pô-lo a minha amiga vaquinha já é um
prazer estar aqui numa conferência do
doté de estética como admirado é menino
bonito ver a sua longa distância durante
muito tempo entretanto ela quer falar
conosco
fiquei estático para mim o hotel é
melhor invenção da humanidade a manteiga
né nas trevas é f
essa história é história conta-se uma
forma muito simples mas que me tornei
xvii
desenhei e 2011 senhor acha que teve
mais ou menos nesse três capítulos
quando caixa é fingir que toda a gente
fez
não é só isso em portugal continental e
fim quando for mais provavelmente para a
ilha de são miguel engrossando os
caixotes e caixotes de pessoas que têm o
costume de trazer pra cá e costuma de
carreira de carregar em alimentos paa a
uma quantidade de idéias pré-concebidas
que quem vive no continente em relação
às ações fiquei muito contente por
verificar que algumas delas se
concretiza um facto que controla móvel
corriqueiro e é impossível não achará
que afinal não fecharam as portas do
paraíso eu pancada mesmo
é só é só comprar um bilhete seja como
for o seu design design na na
comigo é a influência coisas leves como
disney
mônica é uma falta para ser a coisa mais
pesadas pois a marvel não conseguia
falar
é um seja como for o ano no continente
aquela por ser apenas mais um
ironicamente os açores apesar das
limitações físicas espaço ofereceu
espaço psicológico e social
precisava para realmente desenhar
publicamente que é uma coisa que é muito
difícil conseguir fazer a primeira vez
já que é o primeiro passo
as ideias dos projectos eu acho que
somos como água dentro de um balde que é
passado não irmão para apagar o incêndio
e quantas mais mãos - hipóteses a da
água chegar onde incêndio e nos açores
eu acho que há a menos mas precisei é
mais fácil chegar a operar em que
aumenta a influência e possa dar uma
mãozinha ajudar de alguma forma foi mais
simples pôr o pé na porta e começar a
começar a trabalhar naquilo que eu gosto
de fazer é é assim é é mais fácil de
acontecer um sítio onde é na fila paulo
podemos encontrar o secretário-geral do
qualquer coisa nós iela pra começar
melhor e podem procurar os postos novos
casos onde por fazer uma coisa
fantástica que foi evoluí e aprender
conforme fazendo uma coisa raríssima que
que não se consegue fazer não há nenhum
o sávio não sabe eu não pude ir
evoluindo enquanto ia tendo que o
feedback aquela concluindo açúcar o fim
do filme
o design também a olhar a minha
profissão aquilo que realmente posso
fazer roupa desenhada cartoon no heda
muito gosto da psicóloga tipo voluntário
para tentar pôr fim à banda desenhada de
volta na roda dos alimentos mental das
crianças que está completamento da
parceira é muitas crianças que o
encontro nem savassi conhecia a banda
desenhada ea nossa forma das mais
antigas das pinturas rupestres que o
homem comunica com design também fazer
algumas posições permitem também evitar
um livro assouline pergunta que que foi
no mês passado que conseguir fazer isso
e em um e permitiu um ser reconhecido
como tal como um cartunista cada vez que
dizê lo escreveu o cartunista uma
criancinha cá em cima que faço é por
isso por isso consegui
e realmente fazer isso vindo pra cá mas
é assim a facilitismo o facilidade
há uma diferença por facilitismo alguns
carregam as costas nos deixam o tino
a facilidade é dar nas ferramentas e
chegarem ós cinco goleadas de dizer
vamos pra caminhar é tão sexy olímpicos
na esquerda e continua sempre e é esse
ajudar que sentir que via que devia
ficar assim e principalmente numa ilha
nós temos tradução do que a distância é
as distâncias são sinônimos tempo e nós
já temos de ter a noção da quantidade
enorme de tempo perdemos outro ponto a
ao ponto b
eu conheci um casal né na promoção que
tinha uma vida assegurava para efetivos
em lisboa e por isso mesmo se viram um
procriar por 5 0 e praticamente tiveram
uma filha aperceberam se da quantidade
enorme de tempo passam entre casa e
escola escola casa o grupo pega é assim
em casa com a filha dormir chama casa
com o filho dormir e este verão não
vamos fazer isto se vê nos mudar
praticamente fosse preciso viver das
furnas e neste momento no colega saiu da
escola através ou mostrava pega filha
atravessam a estrada está em casa dez
minutos os concursados do caminho e isto
é um acompanhar é realmente centraram
hoje sabemos o que é quem portanto na
nossa vida e contra atacar também uma
grande abertura para tudo aquilo que era
idéias e projetos por exemplo o o toca
da que acontece todos anos não há muitas
cidades a nível europeu que digam
artistas se sim é difícil pinto a
vontade não é fácil encontrar o meu
próprio livro foi preciso uma ajuda
humanitária é ea questão é que de uma
maneira ou de outra não interessa
eu vi o apoio na segunda feira e nessa
história mas o flamengo é assim e é
óbvio que as pastas porque cheira e as
pás para autoconstrução quem tiver
pernas pra fazer o caminho
é possível fazer isto e pode acontecer
que a uefa vai ver um ex opositor vento
por elas' nível paraíso
as pessoas estão a ganhar as suas coisas
estão completamente acorrentadas moisés
as coisas possuímos e acabam por nos
consumir nós é ea questão é que eu tenho
uma colega minha camiseta as suas contas
surgem assim sem mais nem menos
e tu vida toda tem que ver dentro de uma
mala com limite de peso de 20 quilos e e
em 50 conseguir se não conseguirmos nos
livros diz coisas nós temos que ter
noção do que podemos avançar no futuro
os olhos no passado os livros já o lêmur
a uma enfiada maior do livro coolers
comparativamente porque hospital - temos
que que avançar e que sabem o que
realmente quer realmente um exemplo
tanto aqui é óbvio que a relva não é
sempre verde placa mãe
é óbvio que também vai estudo veste mas
que algum simbolismo aníbal capela vai
também um povo não só que gostar mas
também achei que me agarrava ajuda
depois de e que acaba por ficar
levantava mas também uma região que ela
às vezes não vou mais porque tem um peso
em cima que pronto governo mas também um
pouco esperada dogma forma fica agarrado
a sua ampliar sua mury quando vem alguém
para agradar nem sempre trata da melhor
forma quem chega para ordenar a sorte
tudo isto simbolismo por exemplo isso
acontece em todo lá tudo está em todo o
lado
todos os tipos de problema já há em todo
o lado este mesmo quarto de ser feito
futebol continental lisboa no centro vai
ser feito com a europa ao menino o
centro está normal está completamente
que ele já sabe
isto foi o que houve
outros virão outras coisas há quem não
tenha visto nada
eu sempre lembrar de uma cópia conheci
quando cá cheguei o primeiro ano e ter
ficado 18 anos e não sabia o que era uma
terra não tem vergonha java 1
lento e quer ser ou estar aqui chavo é
muito fácil para conca fred e é falar
mal só com muitas vezes dizemos que
roupa do vizinho está suja estendida
suja mas que se não já que espelhar as
nossas janelas e consumidas e convênio é
prevenir o avanço tudo isso também não
estou a dizer que os açores são um filho
do próprio fantástico estão prontos para
comer e que é só chegar entre a boca não
é uma terra de oportunidade mas é uma
terra possibilidade é uma terra
ingrediente que teremos povoa wentao
arregaçar as mangas e se sim ou cozinhar
e fazer tentativa e erro eu entretanto
já ficou calado
só posso dizer uma coisa é exatamente as
possibilidades que o varejo também uma
folha branca que que encontramos casos a
soja foi a braga ea fantástica 29,7 por
21 centímetros de papel branco e em que
que temos tudo aqui nesta folha pode
estar a um design mal um design bom
botar uma receita pronta uma lista de
fabricar votar uma canção votaram os
gostos uma palestra terra mas o fato é
que nós possamos a nossa vida a maioria
da nossa vida é consumir é que os outros
produziram equipe do tipo zero da terra
a folha branca é nossa forma de colocar
alguma coisa que a minha terra deixar
que alguma coisa posso te consumiram de
mais tarde
e o fato é que muitas vezes colocamos
coisas nas folhas de aulas não vamos a
lado nenhum e minha vinda para os açores
foi que permitiu começar a deixar alguma
coisa minha e na terra e é começar a
contribuir de certa forma para aquilo
que é o nosso conhecimento geral nem que
seja
uai